look guys nothing lasts forever so I
don't have any particular impetus to
talk about this terrible idea well I do
I saw several month old nerdsync video
that hanging on around - that was on a
similar vein to what I'm going to talk
about and that was kind of my leaping
off point but basically I want to talk
about cinematic universes because
obviously they are the hot thing right
now you know everybody's got them going
or is trying to get them going seems
like every studio wants to be in the
Cinematic Universe business and I want
to kind of look at what I think might be
the inevitable falling a part of the
core concept now I'm largely going to
talk about this in terms of Marvel this
is not because I think Marvel is the
most likely to fail but because it is
the oldest the most established and I
think at this point it's safe to say the
most stable from a financial and returns
perspective it's the one that I think
makes the most sense in terms of
examining what I want to look at because
when I talk about cinematic universe is
failing coming apart showing their
weaknesses etc I'm not talking about
when you just do it wrong which it looks
like you know the universal is dark
universe off to a rough start I have
certainly argued that the DC EU up until
very recently was being handled wrong
but that's not what I want to talk about
to make an analogy to something that I
don't know very well which is cars what
I want to talk about is the wear and
tear so like all things be equal the car
that's going to fail first is the oldest
one because it's been running the
longest and whatever are the inherent
problems with the vehicle are going to
happen to that first so I'm not what I
don't want to talk about is the car that
was simply driven into a tree because
that's not an inherent problem with a
car that happened that's somebody
completely not knowing how to work the
darn thing so getting off that analogy
talking about Marvel now we have had
Marvel it's almost 10 years now that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has been a
thing and it continues to be a
successful thing and I think it will
continue to be a successful thing into
the future but
depending on what marvel does after
infinity war they could start to see the
thing come apart and where my head got
going with this is what was brought up
in the nerdsync video because in that
one Scott talked about specifically
comparing the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to the Marvel Ultimate Universe and if
you didn't see that video I'm actually
going to link it below because enough of
my ideas kind of spawned from watching
it but I think it's worth giving it that
credit Marvel's ultimate universe was
set up basically as a jumping on point
for new readers who might be intimidated
by decade's worth of continuity that was
bogging that well someone argue bogging
down somewhat argue enriching the main
Marvel Universe
now the Ultimate Universe lasted about
ten years and there's a number of things
that you can point to as to what
ultimately brought down the ultimate
universe Scott talks about some of them
but one of the ones that I think he
didn't give as much credit and I would
give for why the ultimate universe
ultimately had to be closed down which
is that if the goal was to make it a
clean easy jumping on point eventually
it's just not going to be that anymore I
mean it worked great when the things
started you know start from Ground Zero
with all these characters we can make
changes it's not going to have all the
historical baggage new readers can come
in old readers can come in and see what
we're doing different it'll be fun and
it was fun and it works fine for a while
but eventually it creates its own
extended complicated continuity that
becomes a detriment to new new readers
so that and sort of bringing in new
readers new audience is the impetus for
these kinds of side projects or in the
case of DC it's why they keep rebooting
their universe all the darn time and it
was the impetus for the initial
crisis on Infinite Earths look we've got
all these multiverses we're not getting
new readers at the rate we would like
because people are intimidated by all
this stuff let's simplify it so it makes
better sense and we'll get new people
and it and again that worked for a while
until they felt it got too complicated
and they did fine
Oh crisis and they did these other sort
of events that we're tweaking until they
finally rebooted it after flashpoint and
now they're doing rebirth and they just
you have to keep cycling through because
new audiences are an oddly finite
resource theoretically should be an
infinite resource as a new generation
people become old enough to consume your
entertainment you should never run out
of new readers in theory the thing is
though is that intimidation factor that
I talked about I do think is part of the
reason that say in the last decade or so
a lot of very long-running soap operas
have been slowly dying and getting
canceled and I think the reason for that
is eventually new people stopped coming
in or if they don't stop altogether the
growth of new readers new audience
coming in eventually is smaller than the
older audience either deciding they've
had enough or if it's been around long
enough dying off and that just gets you
diminishing returns unless you can find
a way to really fire up supercharge the
new audience and Marvel Cinematic
Universe may be hitting that point soon
because when the Marvel Cinematic
Universe started you had your initial
core group of superheroes building up to
the Avengers now that all worked great
phase one really kind of flawless in
terms of execution I'm not saying the
movies themselves were perfect I'm
saying in terms of structure how they
set it up could each individual film
while connected to the others did not
require you to have watch the others and
I where you can even watch that first
Avengers movie without having seen those
other ones it catches you up well enough
so even the big event one that was a
culmination of all these people could
just jump on there and it was fine but
as we've gone along since then because
they want all the events not only to tie
into each other but to be consequential
to each other so that the events matter
then it makes things become more and
more intertwined and more tightly knit
and it becomes more and more necessary
for people who are very serious about
this to watch everything now
you're a complete geek like I am you are
more than happy to do that but if you
are a mainstream audience and let us be
honest the complete geek audience like
me
we are not enough to maintain this
franchise on our own this has to bring
in mainstream audiences and I think
after infinity war we are at risk for
them starting to become just overwhelmed
by how much back history there is that
they're not caught up on or they didn't
watch you know the latest Thor because
they don't like Thor as much as they'd
like Captain America now suddenly
there's a whole chunk of stuff going to
infinity war that they're not going to
cut up on they're going to be going what
the heck is going on I think there is
potentially depending on how its
executed a certain amount of backlash
that if any war might draw from
mainstream more casual audiences which
is the audience that has made this a
billion-dollar franchise instead of just
a several hundred million dollar
franchise now again everything I'm
talking about here is separate from this
concept of superhero fatigue which is
something that gets tossed out around
can I'd honestly don't think that's a
thing I do think continuity fatigue
could very well be a thing again for
mainstream audiences who are not willing
to put in the investment to watch
everything or to read a wiki on whatever
they weren't willing to watch in the
theater or on Netflix or whatever and
the bigger this universe gets the more
intertwined geeks like me wanted to get
but that is potentially alienating to
the mainstream customers and that is
where things might start to diminish now
this is not necessarily a foregone
conclusion there are ways to mitigate it
I think the smartest thing that Marvel
could do to help stave this off is that
following infinity war is to basically
start over
to go back to smaller less continuity
driven stories for the individual
franchises they need to go back to the
roots of those initial you know two or
three films that were given to
characters like Captain America
like Iron Man like Thor and then have
them be more so contained like has the
references to the other movies in this
universe be Easter eggs not plot central
important points and most importantly
not try and Trump or one-up infinity war
in terms of scale or intertwining or the
coming together of all the characters
for a long time because they are not
going to be able to top at anytime soon
and infinity war could be great I hope
it will be but again I don't believe in
superhero fatigue I do believe in events
fatigue because we've seen it in the
comics themselves I have known more than
a few friends who got really tired of
the continued big events that were just
continuity tweaks or reboots in DC
Marvel has really been overdoing events
on the comics lately they've had like
one a year for a while I think they even
had to in a year like not that long ago
I can't even keep up with all this and
it's a saying that these publishers or
in this case in the case the movies
these Studios tend to get wrong which is
that they look at all the money that's a
big event one like the Avengers pulled
in and go great will do big event ones
but the thing is the big event only
works on the foundation of each
individual franchise which needs to be
on solid footing in the first place or
to bring it into the terms of comics the
big events in comics character deaths
new and new characters introduced
crossovers people turning evil stuff
like that was really only impactful when
it wasn't the norm and it wasn't
happening every other freaking issue
when the loudest thing you have becomes
the normal then that's it everything
just becomes white noise as opposed to
being a peak to a slower standard volume
now this is a case where the realities
of moviemaking
might basically force Marvel films and
Marvel Studios to do the smarter thing
and that is that these actors are not
going to play these parts brother
forever they're either going to age out
of them or they're just going to decide
on their own you know what I've had my
fill and that will force them to
basically retire these characters
characters like Tony Stark and Captain
America
eventually they'll retire some of the
other long runners like Thor and Loki
and all these others and it will force
them to actually pay attention into the
new generation of heroes and like I said
basically start over and I think that
will be a very good thing I think
if basically if actors didn't age we'd
be in a ton of trouble it would just
keep escalating and escalating and
escalating but the realities of
filmmaking are going to force them to do
what they never do in the comics which
is too rich is to slow down back up and
reassess as opposed to keep trying to
one-up all the time because continuity
is fun it's great it's wonderful for
guys like me but like I said guys like
me do not make up a big enough chunk of
the audience to sustain these movies and
continuity can be a big headache for
standard viewers and continuity can also
become just very self aggrandizing where
you're basically padding you know the
longtime fans on the back for noticing
stuff going thanks for sticking with us
here's a cookie but you're not actually
moving things forward in terms of
gaining a new audience and keeping the
thing fresh and revitalized because
continuity cinematic universes haven't
been I think a wonderful thing and I
don't want to see it just come apart at
the seams because no one's paying
attention to the eventual problems no
one's doing the routine maintenance on
the car and no one you know swapping out
parts in the engine when they need to
and I don't want them to just drive the
car into the ground you know to go back
to the analogy of the machine that I
only partially understand so those are
my thoughts on what might be the
eventual demise of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and by extension the impossible
inevitable demise of any successful
cinematic universe and possibly how to
if not stop it at least delay it so what
are your thoughts on all of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter add council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and it's a
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]